internationally I think the United
States is going to have to figure out a
role for itself as what sounds like an
advertising slogan the last remaining
superpower and and on obviously it's not
the cold war anymore something else and
and I don't think that the United States
has quite figured out i think also the
United States is going to have to figure
out how to catch up with other countries
not so much economically but I mean when
it comes to just statistics like infant
mortality and things literacy I think I
think that that the United States is
actually falling behind a lot of ways so
I think we're going to have to figure
out how to
not be simply the people with the
biggest army or the only army I really
wonder what it gets right down to it i
mean i think the united states the last
time i read spends as much money on on
what's called defense although not many
armies of attacking lately as everybody
else put together or pretty close so i
think i think obviously the united
states the question of how the United
States is going to use its power is
still not clear from from the days
following the Cold War
you